nothing says summer like watermelon but
when it comes to cocktails watermelon is
a very challenging ingredient to work
with because there's so much watering
and already if you add ice essentially
more water it dilutes it stretches it
out and you lose that trademark
watermelon flavor but there are ways
around it and I'm going to show you a
cocktail
the retains all of watermelons thirst
quenching glory it is called the
watermelon spritz what you're going to
need for this cocktail is some fresh
watermelon juice a light bitter Italian
liqueur a little bit of vodka and some
Rose a champagne so we're going to build
this drink right in the glass there's no
shaking or stirring because that would
dilute it and we lose that watermelon
flavor the key to a great watermelon
drink is using watermelon juice which
you can get in a number of ways you
could just muddle some in a glass or
container until it's pretty much all
water or you can run us through a juicer
which is the easiest you can also put it
in a blender or a food processor just
blend it right up and strain out the
solids so we're going to have two ounces
of watermelon juice and add it right
into the glass now I can add two ounces
of my bitter aperitif go for something
on the lighter side as bitters are very
concentrated you'll need a few dashes
but bitter liqueurs are very popular in
Italy and France and they are drank all
by themselves in Italy they're called
Amaro's and France they're called at
mayors
both of them just mean bitter so two
ounces of the bitter liqueur it's on the
lighter side so two ounces really isn't
that much alcohol
now half an ounce of vodka just to bump
up the booze a little bit and give it an
extra kick you could use 3/4 full ounce
of vodka if you want it now we're gonna
throw in our ice and now we're going to
add our rose a champagne you can easily
make this drink for a group of people
like putting this all in a pitcher just
add the champagne last because you want
those bubbles to be nice and fresh top
it off about 3 ounces so wow that looks
amazing and finally we're going to
garnish this with a few cucumber slices
and some strawberries surprisingly the
combination of two cumber and strawberry
kind of boosts that watermelon flavor
it just incorporate it a little bit of a
stir and that is the watermelon spritz
perfect for sitting by the pool or in a
cafe on the streets of Italy or just
about anywhere at all if you like that
drink subscribe to the GQ channel for
more